how are you guys doing I've made a video
about Beni pero yesterday and he has
responded he's responded on Pi's
Morgan's uncensored show so let's take a
look at what he says and respond in kind
we're not talking about Hamas we're
talking about children here we're
talking about women here we're talking
about elderly
people you make me sick you make me
sick what's your response to that Ben
mean that will be I'm sure a reaction
You' have heard from a lot of people
what do you feel about that I mean my
obvious response is of course I feel
horrible for the people who are being
held by Hamas in a state of tyranny for
the past 15 years Hamas was the elected
government in Gaza in 2006 there hasn't
been an election since then all the
people who are who are today ranting as
as you heard Muhammad hijab doing right
there I don't hear them talking about
liberating Gaza from Hamas which is the
greatest threat to the to the way of
life of gazin on planet Earth again I
have nothing but sympathy for Hamas for
for the people that Hamas is is
governing or the people that Hamas is
exploiting really I have nothing but
sympathy for civilians there Israel has
to defend itself I don't understand
exactly what the expectation would be
here is is the expectation that because
Hamas uses human Shields that Israel
therefore has to go home and wait to be
to to have its people murdered again
Israel tried it the way that that
Muhammad hijab and others would like
Israel literally pulled in 2005 they
literally pulled thousands of Jews out
of the Gaza Strip it was called the
disengagement and it was massively
unpopular in wide swats of Israel they
they pulled out they built a wall and
they basically said go ahead and govern
yourselves and this is the result of
that you think Israel you think I you
think anyone in Israel no one in Israel
wants to reoccupy the Gaza Strip no one
that's why Israel has been studiously
avoiding reoccupying the Gaza Strip
since 2006 despite the fact that they've
been living underground in large parts
of Israel for weeks at a time because of
Rocket attacks have been fired on a
regular basis from the Gaza Strip now
you'll notice that what he said is that
of course I feel horrible he says of
course I feel horrible for what Hamas is
doing for the last 15 years so you see
the key question that I put forward
which PE couldn't carry over properly
and ask properly by the way which he
asked all Palestinian Representatives do
you condemn the attacks do you condemn
the attacks which was my question to Ben
chapiro do you condemn the attacks he
couldn't and he did didn't and he
wouldn't answer that question why
because everything must be scapegoated
to Hamas everything must be scapegoated
to Hamas even before Hamas was an entity
the terrorism narrative was still in
force by the Israelis against the
secular PLO this cannot and it will not
fly anymore secondly my question to Pi
Morgan is why didn't you ask this man
this same question that you ask all the
Palestinian Representatives do you
condemn the attacks which
disproportionately affect women and
children why is it that the killing of
Jewish men women and children who are
non-combatants must be labeled as
terrorism but that the killing of men
women and children who are in the gazen
Strip by the idea forces where there can
be an alternative motion and I'll tell
you what that is in second is not
condemned what is that thing cuz I said
I say it in a
second they they've made it out as the
this is the only option they said this
is the only option that's not actually
logically the case it's not logically
the case that the only option to fight
Hamas is to disproportionately affect
civilians women and
children what other options are there
face tof face confrontation with Hamas
face-to-face confrontation with Hamas
targeted attacks of them you can attack
them directly and they can you can have
a fight with them one-onone face to face
man to man woman to woman if you got
them in your IDF forces Let them fight
why do you have to kill 95% of the
injured are civilians more than that
maybe 99% of the civilians the people
who have injured our civilians do not
make this out to be the only option we
are not dumb we're not stupid we're not
foolish do not equate Israel has a right
to defend itself with Israel has a right
to annihilate yeah a civilian population
and look what he says he says frankly I
don't believe yeah that the appropriate
a proportionate response to terrorism I
don't believe in a proportionate
response to response to terrorism I
believe that the response to terrorism
should be wildly disportionate response
that doesn't mean targeting civilians
he's using his words very not targeting
them but implicating them yes
implicating the majority of them yes yes
yeah are you telling me that okay it
doesn't mean targeting them but if
you're going to do an action which is
going to assure yeah Beyond reasonable
doubt that the majority Target is going
to be civilians that that's not in a
sense targeting civilians this is a wild
contradiction and I know that you know
that I know that you know that I know PE
Morgan knows that I know Ben Shapiro
knows that I know the daily wi knows
that I know the British public know that
I know the am public know that and I
want to say something when he was
answering the question didn't you see in
his face him stammering and staggering
and and and
stuttering imagine that person who
looked defeated already imagine that
person who he wasn't even with me face
to face he wasn't even responding me on
a Telly link he wasn't even speaking to
me on zoom and he looked like he
himself he looked like he had
himself and soiled himself imagine him
being probed Yeah by by the likes of
someone like me he would himself I
can tell you that for a fact the man
would himself just like the IDF are
themselves from face to- face
confrontation the only thing that they
can do is press buttons in a fortified
place they don't fight you altogether
except in a fortified place or behind
walls that's what you're about low risk
High reward you're coward and you all
know that you're cowards you all know
that you're cowards just like Ben
Shapiro was staggering and stammering
and stuttering and he couldn't even
contain himself and you can see the
butter you can see the effects of the
butterflies in his stomach the diarrhea
being uh created in his his bows because
he couldn't F he knows who I am he's
watching my videos P Morgan is watching
my videos but they would never on a fair
one toone bases come and discuss the
matter with me do you think P Morgan on
Fair Grounds would try and speak to me
about an issue like this or Ben Shapiro
when they know what I'm going to come
with absolutely not don't pretend you
don't know who I am don't pretend that
I'm too small of a fish for you to
understand especially knowing that you
I've had two engagements with your
biggest star Jordan Peterson don't
pretend anymore you've been watching my
videos you know what I'm about your
silence is deafening and your cowardice
is
apparent